[Music]
everybody i got kunal nayar here
elizabeth henstridge and tom reese
harry's their new show suspicion is out
today on apple tv plus how you guys
doing today
good how are you good
good uh so my first question kunal
having just done criminal uk and now
suspicion is there just a different
level of excitement for you for when
you're doing
uh look it's a different uh it's a
different muscle obviously that you use
and it's a
it's exciting for me for obviously for
many reasons but one for being known for
something for so long and to to
challenge myself to see if i belong in a
different genre and as an actor we
always try to do diverse stuff and try
to uh diversify our portfolio and that's
i got to work with a great team and meet
some wonderful people and it was really
a dream
yeah and i think it's
i love that no and i think it's exciting
for people to see you in different
genres and you killing all of them so
really cool here and it continues with
this show now elizabeth when playing
this mysterious character of tara do you
read through the whole script ahead of
time to kind of see where her character
ends up or do you kind of going episode
by episode when it's filming
uh so auditioning for i read the first
two episodes and then we didn't read the
final episode until we were halfway
through filming so i didn't know how the
show was gonna end
and
didn't know who did it if anyone did it
if it was one of us as if it wasn't you
know i had no idea and so that was
really lovely as an actor to sort of be
in the moment um but no i was instantly
attracted to the character i think you
often know even just from the
description of a character if it's
something that you feel like you could
really bring something to and would
challenge you as well
and tara was definitely that for me
yeah and i love how you approach this
very like complicated character it's
exciting i think fans are gonna really
like this character of tara now tom i
love your character of eddie how much of
yourself did you find in this character
of eddie
that is such a good question
yeah tom
do you guys know each other
transformative accent um
i
you
i i think like every character you play
it's just it's you through a different
lens so i find um
and
yeah there of course there are elements
of other characters that i've played
that i bring on to any new job and
you're informed by the past and by
yourself and your experiences in the
world so yeah i mean it's quite chaotic
eddie so
where is he or is he chaos you know
what's amazing uh one of the most
amazing things that i learned working
with tom is he's
so incredibly free in front of the
camera yeah that it's a very dynamic way
as an and it's not it's a very difficult
thing for an actor it's very difficult
to frame up for yeah
but it's a joy it's a joy to be across
that because and you have to be so
absolutely present because in any moment
anything can happen
and it really elicits fresh
uh and honest reactions from the actor
across uh that you're playing across so
it's a great compliment he's very free
in front of the camera thank you so much
that's so nice yeah i think we all just
had a really amazing time on the show
and we were lucky that we all got along
and the creative team and the crew and
everyone behind the camera
um as well were just
amazing at getting the show up and
running whilst we were shooting in a
very difficult circumstances with
the pandemic ongoing um
yeah we can't believe it's coming out
yeah i mean there were times when we
didn't even know if we were going to be
able to finish it obviously so we're
very very humbled february the 4th apple
tv plus tune in today
oh it's today for you
today we're in the future
[Laughter]
this is our first time ever doing press
apparently
i love it um no but i also have to ask
too you share so much great wisdom when
it comes to mental health and taking
care of yourself do you think each
character you take on helps you like
find more wisdom about mental health and
self-care in general
oh that's a good question i don't really
think so i feel like i've really
you know i really separate those two
even though they're one thing but for me
just i acting for me is something that i
love
love probably more than any other hobby
that i have and uh i love finding the
truth in the moment which is probably
what spirituality is um
but no i i think that uh
look i i want to you know i really want
to make sure that all of that stuff
doesn't become a moral high ground place
but becomes a place where people come
and be themselves completely in whatever
capacity that is that you can uh be
peaceful but you can also be nuts i mean
on you know maybe on on in meditation or
very peaceful but you spend you know
half an hour on the golf course with me
and you're like this guy is like a fraud
he's not at all peaceful he's crazy so i
just like to balance those two things
nothing says i love that i like golf
[Laughter]
elizabeth i just wanted to say i loved
your episode of agents of steel that you
directed um has it changed your approach
to acting now doing more stuff behind
the cameras
yeah i'm like no my line's better i'm on
time more
i'm lying
i may ask less questions
yeah definitely i mean being on agents
of shield for so long it was just such a
gift to be able to be on set for that
many hours and you know we had a
different director most episodes and so
just just being able to soak all that up
there was just
nothing like it nothing like
being there every day for six years um
and yeah i think it did in some ways it
makes it harder to act because
you need to just be totally in the
moment as an actor and
if you're thinking as a director it's
not always helpful sometimes it is you
know so it's it's kind of different but
it's definitely something i loved and
found very challenging and i'm kind of
still pursuing so
yeah and i'm excited to see you do more
and everybody check out today kunal
elizabeth and tom crush it in suspicion
that's out opportunity plus the first
two episodes and they'll be coming out
weekly every friday thank you guys so
much for joining me today and hope to
talk to you guys in the future thank you
so much